20 meses después los europeos pueden
viajar de nuevo a eeuu con colas en
varios aeropuertos del continente son
muchos los que esperan con ansias
reunirse con sus amigos y familiares
volamos a houston para ver a nuestro
hijo al que no vemos desde hace dos años
es emocionante porque las restricciones
tienen que cambiar la libre circulación
es necesaria y todas las restricciones
son contraproducentes limitan la
socialización de la gente mi mujer es
estadounidense yo soy alemán y estas
restricciones han afectado a nuestra
familia
restricciones de familia no obstante las
restricciones no se han suprimido por
completo para poder viajar a eeuu los
pasajeros por motivos no esenciales
deberán contar con la pauta de
vacunación completa y una prueba pcr
negativa realizada al menos tres días
antes al viaje un avance que muchos
gobiernos europeos celebran se trata de
volver a reunir a las familias se trata
de asegurar que vas a poder ver a tu
familia y amigos después de años junto
con reino unido a las fronteras de los
26 países del espacio schengen e irlanda
permanecían cerradas desde marzo de 2020
una decisión adoptada por la
administración de donald trump pero que
joe biden decidió mantener y que causó
enfado en la unión europea que permite
la entrada de unidenses vacunados desde
comienzos de verano pero ahora con el 70
por ciento de su población adulta
vacunada completamente eeuu finalmente
avanza con su estrategia de reapertura